and joe rogan the king of all podcasting
a very sharp guy joe rogan
doesn't like the video games he says the
video games are a waste of time
joe rogan is completely
wrong about this i cannot believe it
that i
have got to defend video games but i do
take a listen to joe's point
and video games are a real problem
they're real problem you know why
because they're [ __ ]
fun you don't yeah well i'm i have a
real problem with them
and you you you do them and they're real
exciting but you don't get anywhere
right it's like you could do like like
martial arts right you could learn jiu
jitsu
you'd get obsessed by jiu jitsu and then
three years later
you're you're like an elite jiu jitsu
athlete you're like you're entering in
competitions you're a purple belt
you're moving up yeah you're doing well
you're thinking like i might be able to
open my own school one day that
confidence yeah if i have a hundred
students and those hundred students are
paying me x amount of dollars per month
i can make a living
holy [ __ ] i can have a this would be
amazing and then you see your jiu jitsu
school and your jiu jitsu instructor has
all these students and drives a mercedes
and he's got a nice family and like
that's the future this way you're doing
something exciting and fun and you don't
or you could just be playing video games
three years later you could be that same
kid
just playing video games waiting for the
next vic's whatever the
game is you know next xbox game to come
out
and you're gonna waste your time so on
the one level
joe is making an important point which
is don't waste your time doing fruitless
things
but the way he's making the point is
totally wrong
and it's and i think a lot of people
kind of follow
joe's line of argument here but you
shouldn't because that's one of the one
of the problems that's sailing our
society
joe's point is that anything that cannot
possibly make you money is a waste of
your time
even the way he talks about jiu jitsu he
says yeah look jiu jitsu is great you
work on and jiu jitsu is really great
because then you can start a jiu jitsu
school and make a lot of money
from the students at the jiu jitsu
school
that is for i mean i guess you could in
jiu jitsu but on joe's point that
anything
that can't make you money is a waste of
time not only is that not
true but for the entire history of
western civilization
that has been considered the opposite of
true
actually for the entirety of western
civilization
the things that make you money are
considered relatively
a waste of time compared to the higher
things
what do i mean by that going back all
the way to ancient greece
the the thing that man was built for was
for leisure in a certain sense so that
he could contemplate philosophy so he
could contemplate the good
so that he could focus his mind not just
on the things of this world
but on the things of the higher world
and then in christianity of course this
becomes extraordinarily clear
which is that your point in christianity
is not just to serve
mammon and make a lot of money and build
a lot of big buildings and that's it
for its own sake all of those things can
be fine to do
as long as they are ordered toward the
higher things your ultimate goal
is your salvation your ultimate goal is
to contemplate
god to have the beatific vision to to
work on
the things of the spirit that is what
you've got to do
now we've changed this into like i'm
just on my hustle i'm just on my grind
you know i'm just figuring out ways to
make money
you won't you won't be a rounded person
that way you won't have a culture
what is the word culture the word
culture comes from the same root as the
word cult
it comes from the word like to cultivate
you've got to cultivate the human person
and in order to do that you have to
orient it toward things
that you you want to be cultivated like
so for instance if a
what a society worships will define that
society
if a culture worships money it's going
to become a materialistic culture
we're seeing a lot of that today if a
culture worships sex
it's going to become a licentious
culture
if a culture worships god if a culture
worships the good
it's going to be a better more godly
culture
and that's that's how you've got to
orient yourself
if if you want to have this good culture
you know conservatives used to
they make this mistake a lot the left
they're all kind of materialists in a
certain in a certain way going back at
least to karl marx
but the wright used to care about these
things and then sometime i don't know
sometime in the 80s
the right decided to trade all that in
for like parodies
of the wolf of wall street or greed is
good or something like that
pretend that all our lives are just
about making money that's not a
conservative point of view
and that's not going to give you a
culture if you say okay yeah we're going
to have
just constant churning of every
traditional institution
and just make more money money money
money money then what are you conserving
you're not you're not a conservative at
all
the other reason beyond all of that
those are kind of the highfalutin
reasons the other reason why
why joe's point i i think is a little
misguided here
is people need a break people need to
relax sometimes i'm not saying you don't
want to be a loaf you don't want to be
slothful
but sometimes people need a break they
need to relax
sometimes video games can provide that
they're like a puzzle right it's like
doing a crossword puzzle or a jigsaw
puzzle or something like that
you don't want it to take over your life
and i think that's the point joe's
actually making
but as a it's a little bit of a break i
think they can be perfectly fine and
more importantly if your life is
only oriented toward making money and
filling up your bank account and that's
all just for its own sake for no other
reason
that life is no better than the life
squandered playing video games all day
there is there is another option and
that other option is the thing that
for the entire history of our
civilization has been deemed to be
fulfilling and gratifying and it's the
thing that in our now
culture smashing society we seem to have
forgotten
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
[Music]
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you